la genética es una ventana nuestro
pasado más antigua y nadie lo sabe mejor
que es bastante pavo el científico sueco
galardonado con el premio Nobel de
medicina o fisiología de 2022
una vida de investigación
la paleogenética el estudio del ADN de
especies extintas pero al recibir la
llamada del instituto carolinsca todavía
pensó que le estaban tomando el pelo
al principio pensé que era una broma de
mi equipo
luego escuché que sonaba un poco
demasiado en serio
el científico desarrolló la primera
técnica para secuenciar ADN de decenas
de miles de años de antigüedad algo que
se creía imposible por el daño del paso
del tiempo
no solo sirve para la evolución humana
sirve para investigar muchos otros
grupos para estudiar muchos organismos
como las plantas animales extintos
patógenos Así que hace posible observar
la evolución en tiempo real
en 2010 secuencia por primera vez un ADN
de un neandertal y descubrió una nueva
especie de homínidos los denisovanos
gracias a pavo sabemos que los
neandertales y los Homo Sapiens se
reprodujeron mientras coexistían y que
en nuestro ADN hay pequeños porcentajes
de genética de los denisovanos y de los
neandertales herencias que hoy en día
explican por ejemplo que el sistema
inmune de algunas personas reaccionen
mejor o peor contra el Kobe 19 que
tengan más o menos riesgo de desarrollar
artritis o de tener el colesterol alto
pero sobre todo es una herencia que
explica de dónde venimos los humanos y
cómo Hemos llegado hasta aquí